des milliers de manifestants syriens
rassemblés à idleb pour marquer le 11e
anniversaire de la révolution syrienne
ça fait onze ans mais c'est comme si
c'était le premier jour cela fait onze
ans mais même si 20 ans passe nous
allons continuer à appeler au
démantèlement de ce régime criminel à la
libération des prisonniers et à la
liberté
plus de 5000 personnes ont pris part à
l'un des rassemblements les plus
importants depuis des mois dans cette
dernière enclave résistant au régime de
bachar el assad malgré des veines et
d'offensive meurtrière soutenu par là
aussi dans la foule plusieurs
manifestants brandissent des drapeaux
ukrainiens et des pancartes en guise de
soutien à l'ukraine
ce qu'il se passe aujourd'hui en ukraine
est identique à ce qu'il se passe ici
l'ennemi est le même et le but est le
même nous demandons aux ukrainiens de
tenir bon contre l'invasion criminelle
de la russie
l'intervention militaire de la russie en
faveur du régime de damas en 2015 a
changé le cours de la guerre
anéantissant les espoirs de millions de
syriens ou de renverser le régime
fortifier vos hôpitaux avec des blocs de
ciment l'ennemi poutine ne fait pas de
distinction entre civils blessés et
combattants les manifestants espèrent
que l'invasion lancée en ukraine le 24
février par moscou soutenu ouvertement
par bachar el-assad suscitera un nouvel
intérêt pour leur propre cause le
conflit a provoqué plus de cinq cent
mille morts et 13 millions de déplacés à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur de la syrie